c'était en 2012
cindy emilie poster cette démo sur
internet
l'aboutissement d'un parcours de
danseuses débuté en martinique avant un
départ à l'âge de 15 ans pour l'hexagone
et une formation pluriel consacrée par
un diplôme du conservatoire supérieur de
paris
depuis la jeune martiniquaise a fait du
chemin sur scène mais aussi dans des
clips et dans des pubs pour vivre de sa
passion
il faut s'ouvrir à plein de choses on
n'est pas qu'une seule chose dans la vie
donc dans la danse
en tout cas si ça ça ça m'intéresse la
personne en tout cas moi ça m'a
intéressé de s'offrir à plein de danse
donc ils pop et jazz contemporain et
classique plein de choses et aussi à de
la photo à la vidéo à la comédie c'est
hyper intéressant c'est l'art en général
donc on ne s'ennuie jamais aujourd'hui
cindy fait son retour au pays natal
c'est à l'atrium dans un spectacle
intitulé 2147 et si l'afrique
disparaissait c'est un regard posé
raconté chanté et dansé sur ce continent
sur les inquiétudes et les espoirs qu'il
suscite
je commence à travailler sur ce projet
j'ai pensé à césaire c'est penser à moi
laminaire
ce recueil de poèmes qui m'a aidé
d'ailleurs puisque j'ai envoyé aux
acteurs et artistes
j'habite là que j'ai demandé à chacun de
réagir à ce poème de sévères donc les
exciter la déplorer si on parle en
demeurant cible je reviens la cmq avec
un spectacle fessionnels je pense que
c'est un sujet important qui cas pour la
caraïbe et que ça nous touche aussi le
spectacle avait été créée il ya treize
ans à bamako le voici donc aujourd'hui à
fort de france
l'occasion pour cindy de se produire
devant les siens joli voyage pour une
danseuse qui revient en martinique un
passant par l'afrique
[Musique]